[Music]
if a friend asked to borrow $100 from
you would you do it you're probably
thinking that depends on the friend are
they trustworthy have they borrowed
money from me before and if so did they
pay it back borrowing money is as old as
civilization itself and for a long time
it was based on personal relationships
and recommendations the only way for a
lender to know whether they could trust
someone to pay them back was by knowing
them personally or if someone else they
already trusted vouched for them but
when credit became big business lending
companies needed a more efficient way to
decide which borrowers they could trust
so in 1956 a data analytics firm called
fair Isaac and company started creating
mathematical models that used a
borrower's history to measure their risk
and in 1989 they debuted the first
industry standard algorithm the FICO
score this formula was soon adopted by
the big three credit reporting bureaus
Equifax Experian and TransUnion your
FICO score is a three-digit number
between 300 and 850 that indicates to a
lender how safe it is to lend money to
you a high score tells a lender you'll
probably pay the money back on time so
they're more likely to give you a loan
with good terms a low score signifies
that you might not be able to pay the
money back so if they're willing to
offer you credit at all they'll want to
be compensated for the risk by charging
more interest but it's important to
remember this number doesn't represent
who you are as a person or even whether
you are financially responsible there
are people with high credit scores who
live paycheck to paycheck and people
with low credit scores who saved likely
little chip max your credit score only
reflects your past relationship to debt
every time you borrow or repay money
like taking out a credit card or making
a student loan payment the lender
reports that activity to the credit
bureau where it goes into the math
machine but not all data is judged
equally the largest percent of your FICO
score is based on your payment history
so missing a payment is one of the worst
things you can do but thankfully late
payment dings are like broken boats they
may hurt for a while but they eventually
heal as long
you don't break that same bone again a
close second is your credit to debt
ratio if you have a thousand dollar
limit on your credit card with a balance
of 750 you're using 75 percent of your
available credit hovering close to your
limit is like driving on empty which
looks risky to credit bureaus so you'll
want that ratio to be under 25 percent
when someone checks your credit that's
why paying down credit card debt can
really help your score the length of
your credit history makes up 15 percent
of your score it's based on the ages of
your various accounts and it's why older
people often have higher scores than
younger people it's also why getting a
credit card early but using it
conservatively can help you have a
higher score later in life 10 percent of
your score is based on credit diversity
there are three main types of credit
revolving aka credit cards installment
like student loans and car loans and
mortgages an ideal credit report has a
mix of all three the last 10% comes from
new lines of credit and credit checks or
pulls if you apply for a bunch of new
credit cards in a short period of time
or if many different lenders have to
check your score that can be a red flag
though there are exceptions if you're
shopping for a car loan or a mortgage
you'll usually have a window of one to
two months in which multiple credit
pools won't affect your score match also
this only refers to pulls done by
potential creditors called hard polls
soft polls by insurance companies or
employers won't count against you the
FICO model is the main way your score is
calculated but there are many variations
depending on what the lender wants to
know about you and remember your credit
score is not the end-all be-all of
financial health but there are life
goals that a good credit score can make
a lot easier to achieve like owning a
house or starting a business if you want
to know what your score looks like many
credit card and auto loan companies
provide it on your monthly statement
alternately the big three credit bureaus
are required by law to provide you with
a free credit report once a year but
they'll only calculate a score for a fee
and don't worry that's considered a soft
pull and won't hurt your score it may
seem a bit creepy that these faceless
organizations are monitoring your
activities
in order to pass judgment on you but
it's really just our modern version of
having a good borrowing reputation in
which case the same old rules still
apply try to borrow as little as
possible and pay it back on time and
that's our two cents
[Music]